then I come up to him and he shoots me
in the shoulder with a giant metal spike
and then as soon as I pulled that spike
out I guess shot again in the hand so
what did you do then Isaac so I shot him
in the throat you you you shot him uh
Isaac it's not nice to kill people what
do you care if I kill people you killed
the pizza guy he didn't even do anything
hey that pizza guy was a terrorist
anyways guys I can't wait to get our new
suits oh yeah we're getting our armor
upgraded today this is gonna be awesome
oh that's why we are getting our armors
upgraded today we better get going
because we got to get on that we better
get out of here and go upgrade
well let's get going guys
I hope this doesn't hurt as much as it
used to know
Wow everything looks so much better
animate I mean uh this suit rules hey
Isaac what's up hey chief looking good
where Sam is that oh I don't know where
samus is I think she's back at the house
well let's get down to the house and see
how she looks
hey Samus what you doing shooting stuff
well uh you shot chief in the face oh
man you smudge my helmet you jerk uh hey
chief calm down I was aiming for your
crotch not your face let's see how you
like getting shot in the face
alright armor I forgot all right guys
looks like I better go back to my first
day of work in a long time you better be
careful you know it'll happen Isaac I
don't know if it's a good idea for you
to go back to work I'm positive things
will be fine it's your decision see you
later see you later man this helmets
really stuffy hold on let me get it off
oh it's really stuck on there man your
helmet it is stuck what if i start
suffocating oh wait there's a breathing
intake but still pretty claustrophobic
let me try something wait Sammis what
are you doing that's not a good idea
come on that is really stuck
hang on I got another idea
wait what is that a promo what do you do
well that didn't work either wow this is
a cool helmet
hi I'm Isaac Clark I'm back from my paid
vacation well mr. Eisen sir what wait
will read on vacation for again ah you
don't want to know oh you're that mr.
Isaac sir so what jobs do you have for
me
so you've got two jobs for you there is
a class for cruiser out in the gamma
sector and I was having some engine
problems uh oh wait it disappeared three
years ago and came back a month ago it
oh yeah the rescue team that found it
kept seeing skeletons all over the floor
and people kept hearing shrieks and dark
rooms and kept disappearing oh and yeah
sometimes the walls bleed but i'm sure
that's just some technical what jews it
is fun it's fine fine no problem there
I'll take the second one chief are you
sure this isn't too drastic trust me
samus I know what I'm doing and if this
doesn't get the helmet off nothing will
you could decapitate yourself sure it'll
be perfectly safe is the guy getting in
the truck
you
idiot man I should have taken that other
job I don't know anything about plumbing
some sort of now the air did I twist it
and I don't know this is what's this
gonna do is going to do anything
and apparently that did nothing
hi mr. Isaac sir uh you're Kong because
of some kind of problem hey Derek about
that job you gave me I have no idea what
I'm doing well why did you take the job
if you didn't know what you're doing
yeah it doesn't matter well I can send
someone to help you can send someone
over here to help some plumber named
Mario but his files missing a lot of
important stuff all I know is that it
says he's highly recommended but that's
from some guy named luigi I don't know
well uh I'll send him down there soon as
I can you'll get him a couple minutes
come back panting else goes wrong all
right then if a necklace of grenades
doesn't work well then I don't know the
way I see it either my helmet comes off
or my head does so pull the string this
is gonna work
this is a really good helmet it's a me
mario hi there mr. mario so i'm not sure
exactly which pipe is ruptured because i
honestly have no idea about any of this
can you help me out with that it's a me
mario uh you said that already am I here
to save the baby you're kind of freaking
me out dude settle down so has it gone
uh Derek yeah this guy is kind of
creeping me out and he's given the fuzzy
I to the turtle what oh sure he might be
a little creepy he's a plumber they're
kind of creepy people right I mean he's
staring at a turtle and a funny would
now he's jumping all over the place what
the heck is he doing good lord right are
you serious did he just kill oh man oh
jeez now he's jumping up and down on the
flagpole outside okay either it's his
brother or the police I'm sending
someone okay just hold on
all right Luigi you're his brother oh
I'm sorry about my brother he's had a
brain damage since he was four ever
since then he's had this unreasonable
hatred of turtles so you can tell me how
to fix this right and about your problem
with a plumbing system all right all
right I'm listening all you have to know
darn it Mario you killed him oh wait
he's all right it's me Luigi I'm a fine
oh crap okay what do I do now there's no
reasoning with them so i won't reason
with them die Luigi's a breaking my back
oh my spine Mario he's a breaking my
neck taste of my own organs my insurance
won't cover this now he's hitting me
with a pipe okay so now that I've got
you both tied up down here all you need
to know is what to do how do i fix this
hmm well this pipe looks broken dang it
this is too hard wait that actually fix
it this whole time it was just that
little crooked pipe I'm never going to
work again well at least not till
tomorrow
ah there's nothing left to do I'm stuck
this way hey chief what's up samus what
you guys doing yeah we really can't get
his helmet off so his helmet stuck on
hmm have you tried pressing this button
here what button on the back of the
helmet there's not a button on the back
of the helmet there's a button yeah
there's a button here it's totally a
button dudes says release vacuum-seal
helmet hey it's working the helmets
loose I can get it off I can't believe
you fixed it Isaac I guess that worked
chief try taking your helmet off oh
thank god finally no I've actually never
seen you without your helmet I wonder
what its gonna look like wow I've never
seen you without your helmet chief just
like isaac finally ah
well huh son of a